♪ ("WHALES" BY
HAIL MARY MALLON PLAYS) ♪
-PATRICK: Hey! What's up?
-SPEAKER: Where're we going
into?
We're going into
Civic Development Group.
And what we do,
is we call up people
and chisel 'em outta money.
♪ Money on my
Muthafuckin' mind ♪
Patrick and I both work
at this telemarketing place.
I was just this 14-year-old
kid making calls
on behalf of charities.
It's like a big-ass cookout.
♪ Get money ♪
♪ Money out my
Muthafuckin' mouth ♪
SPEAKER 2: I didn't think I was
doing anything bad at all.
Now, Lisa, these families,
they do need your support.
The business model is defrauding
the most vulnerable in this
country.
-It was a big-time scam.
-This is capitalism.
♪ Get money, money, money... ♪
SPEAKER: We need to show the
world what this place really
does.
The media and the government
haven't been able to stop them,
so now, it's up to us.
PATRICK:
♪ Money on my
Muthafuckin' mind ♪
SPEAKER: Pat and I had vowed
to expose the industry.
And it seemed to be evolving
into something bigger
and weirder than ever.
Political action campaigns.
SPEAKER 4: Robocalls.
SPEAKER 5:
Federal Trade Commission.
SPEAKER 6: Congress.
This guy does not
wanna talk to us,
so we figured
we'd get something to eat.
Oh! There he is. Leave the food.
Go! Go, go, go, go, go.
♪ Get money ♪
SPEAKER 7:
Regulating telemarketing is like
regulating Somalian pirates.
It just can't be done.
You're like a whistleblower.
SPEAKER 8:
They don't want us here, bro.
SPEAKER 9: Dude!
Let's just go, Sam.
SPEAKER 10:
There's no turning back.
♪ Money, money, money... ♪
They were calling,
and the initials were CASH.
So, they would tell you,
"Make the check out to C-A-S-H."
Wake up! Smell the coffee.
♪ Money on my
Muthafuckin' mind ♪